gérard collomb n'a pas perdu tant quatre
heures après avoir été nommé ministre de
l'intérieur l'homme politique est venu
au commissariat de trappes pour son tout
premier déplacement officiel
objectif rencontrer les forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain
il a également évoqué avec eux la sphère
malik du nom de cet homme soupçonné
d'assassinât et de tentatives
d'assassinats plaisir et attrapes
je pense que c'est quelque chose
évidemment de dramatique qui est
extrêmement grave et plutôt que d'aller
visiter des lieux vous effectivement il
n'y a pas de difficultés j'ai souhaité
venir ici pour me faire expliquer la
problématique ce que font les enquêteurs
et comment on va arrêter le plus vite
possible
ce criminel gérard collomb a été
accueillie par le maire socialiste de la
commune guy malandain deux hommes qui se
sont côtoyés sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
il ya une
un plaisir humains dans la rencontre
après que le musée l'intérieur ait
choisi de venir ici je le prends comme
une préoccupation par rapport à un
évènement familial qui s'est passé un
qui n'est pas un événement de la ville
pour l'accueillir également une dizaine
de militants de la république en marche
pour eux cette visite de 20 minutes est
un signe fort envoyé par le nouveau
gouvernement
tout ce travail comme disait le
président dès sa nomination il est venu
à trappes pour nous soutenir
c'est très bien au moins on va là tu non
on n'y a pas de paroles là on voit la
direccte là ça c'est très bien moi je
trouve gérard collomb ensuite poursuivi
sa visite dans les yvelines par une
rencontre avec les gendarmes de saint
germain en laye et des pompiers à
chanteloup les vignes